Jennifer first of all huge
congratulations how are you feeling
right now after that Madness that just
ensued over the chessboard I
I highly I don't even know what I was
doing I did it again I hunt a piece
against her again on like move five and
I was like there's no way that I lose
the U.S Championship because I hate him
Bishop against Irina twice like I was
like first time bad enough and then I
was just like oh my God it's probably
over and then you know when there's no
increment how did you manage to get
yourself back mentally at that point
after you just played the move Bishop to
G4 and you looked at Chris bird and did
he confirm that yes it's not only touch
move you drop the piece it's it's done
yeah yeah no because it was like
instincts and Blitz usually it's like
clock me or something so you're like oh
can I do but and I was like well nothing
left to lose absolutely I was like I was
like oh is it over I might as well just
you know make things a little tricky um
I only had like one chance here and
um and then she played that move G4 and
it felt like she's weakening her King a
little bit and then you managed to find
that Bishop takes H2 on the board did
you feel like once again you're gaining
some chances in the position yeah I
think objectively still losing but I was
like you know no increment
um everything is up for grabs and then
honestly at the very end there it was
all based on flagging like it's kind of
crazy that you know two and a half weeks
of work comes down to those few seconds
but um I guess that's chess and even in
the second game you are doing quite well
with the black pieces you have draw odds
and at some point she played the move
with one second on her clock did you
realize that no I was probably doing the
same thing I had no idea I was like
keeping an eye out but I was just I
definitely like should not have thrown
the game like that but um I just could
not think anymore I so that was why like
the last game I was just trying to move
fast and you don't even thinking you
just drop a piece was like maybe this
passes on online chess but you know she
just takes it it's like a pre-move
Jennifer you are the US junior girls
Champion 2022 you are the US Women's
2022 Champion how do you feel right now
I mean I have to say I'm a little happy
I feel pretty good
um honestly did not think that I would
pull this off here at this tournament
just because the way I was playing like
I'm not very happy with the quality of
my games and
um like just heading into the tournament
and feel ready I was prepared so
um I honestly didn't know if I could do
it because I knew I like should be able
to because I've done this once before
and once you've done it it just feels so
much easier but it was just
I don't know I just had so many things
going on too like my head was like
completely in the game and then
um I just kept having like a roller
coaster like I would win a few games and
lose yeah and then it was like oh no
more chances but I mean there always
were chances but like in my head I was
like you know time to focus on you know
school or something and then and then I
winning it and then I'd be like Oh I'm
back in the game and then you know every
time I'm like so close and then there's
like something happens what were the
types of positions that you were looking
for in this matchup because Irena hasn't
lost a single game up to uh this match
what were the type of positions that you
were looking for I really just wanted to
get like a dynamic um imbalance kind of
position I wasn't I didn't really
prepared to specifically opening wise
because also I knew she was going to
switch things up
um I was just I didn't want like a
really boring like um kind of position
where she can squeeze me because I think
that's like our differences in style
like I'm really good at you know
creating messes I like to create message
is um and I think she like wants the
opposite so that was kind of my goal
guys any questions for our champion
I think we're calming down still
Jennifer I think we've got the
butterflies over here
a big congratulations wow I can't just
win a tournament I have to you know
throw away a few for Content yeah
exactly exactly but wow we were on the
edge of a seat for three games in a row
I have a question like such a you won
now just right now forty thousand I mean
what are you going to do is such a great
uh price and how are you going to
celebrate today how am I going to
celebrate and how will you spend your
money
I mean I feel you know
I like to buy clothes but also more
importantly for me you know tuition is
something big so that helps cover it but
I haven't even thought about it yet
because I just like I feel like
I don't know I just didn't expect like I
think it's like when you know that it's
possible but you're not sure if it's
gonna happen
um yeah so I have to really think about
that oh I would go to Thai food first
Thai food yeah why not good good
decision
yeah yes good decision that's crazy
Jennifer our congratulations really a
remarkable wow Jennifer won two titles
so I just wonder which title like you
feel it's more valuable for you
first time and what which emotions do
you have right now like if you compare
them
well the first time it happened I just
didn't know it was possible
um like I was I had the same situation I
was half a point leading going to second
last round didn't even think about
winning
um because I didn't think I could do it
and then it happened so it was a
completely different experience because
it kind of put my open the doorway for
me to be like oh it's possible to you
know win a tournament like this and then
what else could this could this lead to
um so that was something that was really
valuable for me for this one I just
think this was a unique kind of
challenge like I've never played a
tournament like this in college it was a
different kind of experience because I
was you know doing a couple hours
homework too every night
um and also you know I definitely my
games were very
um some of them are quite not too pretty
to look at but it was definitely like a
really good mental challenge especially
since
um the way I lost my game against Irina
around 12 and I came back from it like
I'm really proud that you know I didn't
just kind of give up the tournament is
it was really hard for me to accept that
loss because it was just how can you
lose in that way so I think um I
definitely took really valuable lessons
from both of these events
also I noticed that today Jennifer came
to the tournament with the smile you
were really kind of in a good mood did
you feel that you're going to win or not
at all
how is
I guess I'd say I was nonchalant because
I did not feel right going into this
um I felt like I needed to prep more and
then I realized like it's so fast it's
truly so fast like you can't really know
what to expect especially like this
ending here like I don't think anyone
could have guessed this would happen
would have happened so I didn't know
that I was someone but I was like no
matter what's going to happen it'll be
okay like it was good effort
um because
like I said like this tournament I
learned so many things from this
tournament already yeah
yeah thanks a lot Jennifer Jennifer
congratulations great job great spirit
well done